so what should we do garyvee let's wrap
this up what should we do what should
people do people should [ __ ] stop
complaining right people should figure
out all the [ __ ] they are good call
people should not listen to America
propaganda of fixing the [ __ ] they suck
at they should be tripling down and what
they're good at they should be confident
in certain areas but you're not gonna
become Beyonce or you know like your
bone structure is a certain way like
you're not gonna solve everything your
IQ can get a little bit better but don't
worry about the incremental figure out
what you [ __ ] put you on fire and your
halfway decent at if you're lucky enough
right now to be listening and you're
good at what you like become Tunnel
[ __ ] vision because there's way too
many voices telling you what and how and
here's the other thing and this is the
big one yo because if a humongous
audience the biggest thing that I've
seen dividends from have the
conversation with the person that's
holding you back the reason most people
who listen right now we're not doing
that thing is they're worried about the
opinion of somebody usually their mother
their father and the reality is is that
your spouse may be the person holding
you back and you have to have that
conversation we have to get to a place
where you're doing you because the
number one thing that scares the [ __ ]
out of me is regret and you're gonna sit
there at 72 and you say I wish I wish I
wish
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family there's a million
ways to do this not everybody wants to
buy the Jets not everybody wants a
smoked weed on the beach and Bahamas
like everybody's got a different [ __ ]
thing figure out what your [ __ ] thing
is and stop making [ __ ] [ __ ]
excuses who the president is your mom
did this like like I missed it I had
that idea for uber then why don't you
[ __ ] do it dick
you